I guess it was the second time in my
life I felt
betrayed um the first time was
when I
um I was whatever young
17 and I got
arrested I was with all these older guys
tough guys
whatever and um
supposedly and uh the detectiv separated
us that's what they do and um you know
they they asked me who did whatever
who's gun this that you know all that
the particulars of obviously what we did
and you know it was me and um they said
you sure you don't want to change that
you don't want to because your friends
changed it and and these cops they were
nasty but they were cops they were the
way you know you're going to wind up in
Rikers with and they're going to be
doing this to you and I want even say
the things because then why say them you
know figure it out but you know they're
trying to get what they're trying to get
and you know you want to change it and
um
no and but I felt very betrayed you know
yeah and um especially when I was
standing in the in the cell in rikus
looking at the airplanes leave luati
airport and then hoping I was on one you
know I was making like a deal with God
let me be on one of those planes and let
it crash I'll take a shot was part of
you proud that you didn't give up your
friends no because I didn't understand
what proud was I didn't understand
nothing I just understood that um rules
are rules you're just loyal and that's
it I didn't even know there was an
option I didn't think there I know the
cops said you could do this but that
there was no option my father never had
an
option but the betrayal the private
betrayal was like and so when
cuz we were Partners me and cus yeah cus
was
retired this stupid kid goes up there
and all of a sudden I start training
Fighters first I won the gloves cuz put
me in the gloves I won the gloves that I
had injury whatever but bottom line is I
still want to fight I want to turn pro I
want to fight that was the plan and
um and cuz had a different plan
cuz cuz was like you can't and he had it
set up a little bit whatever without
getting into it hey he did me a favor
and I I'd like to think he knew he was
doing me a favor and you know what I do
think he was he was doing himself a
little bit one too but but he was doing
it for the greater cause because he
believed in this thing of boxing he he
believed that it changed lives he
believed that it was worthwhile he
believed that there was a power to it
beyond the left hook the big picture of
boxing yeah he believed in it yeah he
believed that To Be A Champion you had
to be special you had to be smart you
had to have character you had that you
had to be a better person and that you
couldn't make a champion if you didn't
make him a better person first and and
that that this you know this could
strengthen people the sport could
strengthen people in those ways
so he he was married to it and he he was
old and he needed there was no one in
his gym it was
empty and it was above a police station
which was crazy and he needed an air to
the throne he needed to pass it on to
someone and he saw something and all of
a sudden he said he saw that my career
as a box was less important than having
me become his a to the Drone and become
his trainer his man his guy to continue
that we could do a lot more for him and
for for for everyone not not just for
him but for everyone it was more like to
keep it going like it couldn't die it
couldn't die and cin was afraid to it
would die with him and he committed his
whole life to it he didn't get married
because of boxing so he didn't so he saw
me as as you know the the little bit of
you know the seed to plant for for more
things to grow and before that plant
died and so he all of a sudden she came
fight and I had people tell me that I
could go somewhere else and fight mhm
and I could MH but I couldn't right
because I'd be disloyal loyalty is
everything yeah so I couldn't leave CZ
yeah and he kind of knew that and and so
you know I couldn't leave him and he
said you have an ability to teach he
said knowledge means
nothing he said see these pranica he had
pran pranica encyclopedia uh the whole
set in in our library he said you see
these yeah I see them all the knowledge
of the world whatever uh is in these all
right means nothing if you don't have
somebody to convey it to people
otherwise it just sits on a bookshelf it
looks good he goes you have the ability
to convey knowledge to people you're a
teacher you were born to be a teacher
you lessen Yourself by only being a
champion fighter because you'd only take
care of one person you could take care
of all kinds of people and you could do
this and you could do that and you could
do this so we go on this Venture took a
minute cuz I didn't believe him at first
but finally we I am I'm there I'm
training
Fighters and then he he gets me to buy
in and I I was a teacher and I start
teaching these kids and there's no one
in the gym it's dead and all of a sudden
there's 10 kids 15 20 25 30 35 40 45 cat
scill boxing club which was never there
now it's there and I'm training Fighters
I'm taking down the South Bronx to get
experience one of his former Fighters
NOS quis down the South Bronx I'm taking
down there to get smokers to get fights
when they're ready after I'm wearing out
dungar I'm getting holes in my dung I
was fashionable before it was
fashionable to have holes in my dungar I
could have made a lot of money with that
because I was on my knees with these
little kids 9 years old 10 years old 8
years old 10 12 13 14 all these kids and
and I'm teaching and I'm building a gym
and cuz only came once a week because he
was semi-retired you know and and he's
and when he would come once a week he
knew he couldn't give me money but he
gave me more than money he gave me
praise MH and he said look what Atlas is
doing he's creating Champions and I was
like wow yeah wow I'm I'm doing good and
and and and then all of a sudden after
four years of that because I was up
there seven years eight years eight
years after about three and a half four
years of that we get a phone call that
they got this kid in prison and TR on
Prison uh from one of the guys that knew
cus Matt Baranski uh and and there's a
state there's a correction officer named
Bobby Stewart who used to box and cus
had helped him out a little bit a little
bit and um and they knew we had this gym
now that was really starting to become
something because we were winning
tournaments and everything else the go
we got this kid Mike Tyson he he's he's
12 years old he's 190 lbs he's a mess
but Bobby Stewart got involved with him
uh you know the the former fighter and
he's taking a liking to it and now where
he didn't behave at all and he didn't
listen to anyone now he's listening
because Bobby's got a carrot and the
carrot is hit H teacher boxing and now
he he's at the point now where we we
want you to take a look you and Teddy
all right bring them
down